h
hahaha
ohne
willkommen
mit der ukulele ja meine lieben freund
ich glaube ich lass uns mal lieber mit
der ukulele hier ich kann das eh nicht
spielen
ich wollte euch nur herzlich willkommen
heißen zu einer weiteren bot vorstellung
heute hier am samstag immer leicht ist
wie du vielleicht ein bisschen später
kommen zu gegen 18 19 uhr also
normalerweise kommen die am samstag
sinken wie man so gegen 23 oder so um
den dreh aber freuen der bielefelder
gespielt des verbundes liga und gewalt
und prioritäten setzen jedenfalls habe
ich für euch wieder eine coole
modifikation vorbereitet und zwar ist
dass die t-labs modifikation das ist
nämlich eine modifikation die
teleportation möglichkeit hinzufügt ich
habe euch erinnern damals mal die team
fortress 2 mod vorgestellt wo die auch
so teleporter drin waren aber die hier
sind ein bisschen cooler deswegen zeige
ich euch erstmal das crafting rezept das
das einzige was ihr benötigt und zwar
zwei redstone links zwei redstone rechts
zwischen den redstone einer entfernung
ein eisen block und darüber drei glas
dann bekommen wir zwei tele platten
ja wir bekommen zwei daraus weil man
benötigt immer zwei ersetzt im creative
das ist ja egal weil ich eh ich weiß gar
nicht was diese schafe wollen im koma
meine lippen sehen so aus als diese
stadt braucht
ja das liegt an der an der kamera
softbox crazy diese tele pad
modifikation da müsst ihr quasi einfach
nur dieses crafting rezept machen dann
bekommt ihr zwei von diesen tele platten
die kann ich jetzt beispielsweise mal
hier setzt sich mal eins hin
damit ihr das mal seht das ist doch dann
direkt ist man in dieser namens wii drin
in diesem dings hier und zwar steht als
planes weise einfach das bios und dann
gib deiner testet tele platte einen
namen und dann schilder schon planes
drücke enter um zu bestätigen ich nenne
das jetzt aber mal anders ich nenne es
beispielsweise mal zu hause dann seht
ihr schon das verändert sich und auch
dann drücke ich einfach enter und jetzt
habe ich hier die erste platte wo
zuhause draufsteht und ich habe hier
einen tele platten registriere bekommen
da ist jetzt quasi meine zuhause platt
und wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise mal
hier in dieser wanne fliege und hier
jetzt mal eine platte hinsetze seht ihr
schon wenn ich hier eine platte hinsetze
steht hier savannah ich nenne das jetzt
aber beispielsweise mal bei der ukulele
irgendwie so und dann ist das hier
beispielsweise hier wurden dann die
ukulele sagen wir hier wo die ukulele
und da hinten ist mein zuhause
und wenn ich mich jetzt drei sekunden
lang hier raus stelle die die schon da
kommen immer mehr so teile hier zu mir
hin blablabla so sieht viel krasser aus
dem who damit ich in einem bildschirm
oder das habt ihr wahrscheinlich auf dem
sampler gesehen dieses komische das ist
ein bisschen hin und her und dann habe
ich hier entweder zu hause oder bei der
kollege und ich kann auch ex drücken
wenn ich extrem wenig quasi weg ich
könnte jetzt weggehen
ich bleib mal drauf und zeigt euch dann
das jetzt was passiert wenn ich
beispielsweise jetzt auf zuhause clique
nämlich werde ich danach zuhause
teleportiert und wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise keine tele platten mehr
habe könnte ich mir beispielsweise
einfach wieder neu machen mit dem
crafting rezepte vorne
sagen wir mal ich hätte mir drei stücke
macht dann kann ich jetzt mehr rein
theoretisch hier oben auch noch eine
hinsetzen und zwar besitze ich hier mal
einfach eine hinter steht dann desert
hielt beispielsweise das nenne ich jetzt
beispielsweise mal einfach wüste
ja das ist richtig geschrieben und dann
sieht das ganze muss ich natürlich erst
mal hoch kommen dann sieht das ganze so
aus wenn ich mich jetzt einfach hier
drauf stellen
und da kann ich hier bei der ukulele
klicken und dann bin ich wieder hier bin
ich natürlich direkte drin gewohnt aber
ich denke ihr wisst was ihr euch zeigen
möchte das sind einfach so diese
funktion der tele pad dann gibt es noch
ein paar extra sachen und zwar ist diese
ganz modifikation erst mal wenn ich hier
beispielsweise mal ins backstage pack
rein packe das ganze ist sehr geil
gemacht auch mit zwecks und zwar
verändert sich dann die komplette textur
und ihr seht auch schon die partikel
verändern sich und wenn ich hier drin
mit verändert sich unter anderem auch
dieses komplette bild was ich hier
bewegt das ist dann einfach hier so ein
anderes bild ich weiß nicht warum aber
hier auch wie andere schriftarten und so
werden beispielsweise wieder auflöste
clique bin ich hier und wenn ich
beispielsweise jetzt nico und ich drücke
jetzt mal rechts seht ihr im chat
support oh gott open university of the
universe ist also jetzt ist es nämlich
so auf servern können jetzt freunde von
mir mein bett neben zu deren koordinaten
hinzufügen und müssten dann nicht extra
dann bräuchten wir halt nicht so wenn
ich auf server beispielsweise und wir
haben den berg entdeckt und haben uns
hier eine base drauf gebaut zu zehnt
dann müssen ich muss sich jeder sein
eigenes teleport ahl machen sondern man
kann einfach beim also muss ich nicht
jeder eine platte machen sondern es kann
hier einfach einer machen der kann das
stiften und rechts hinten drauf machen
dann ist die jetzt die closed und ihr
seht schon wenn ich die aufgaben
verändert sich auch die farbe von den
teilen hier die es so zu lila oder geht
wieder an andere farbe also jetzt ist
die open air jazz die klaus und dann
würde ich ihr quasi ohnehin machen würde
die so öffnen und jeder könnte dann
quasi darauf zugreifen wenn ihr versteht
was ich meine und allgemein haben wir
dann auch was sie vorhin wahrscheinlich
gesehen habt am anfang als ich die erste
platte gesetzt habe ich diesen tele
platten registriere bekommen da kann ich
einfach auch so shift rechts drauf
machen dann sehen wir eine kleine
bedienungsanleitung
erstens teleportieren stell dich auf die
platte und warte drei bis fünf sekunden
das haben wir schon gemacht entfernen
der platte recht die tele platte das sei
jetzt nehme ich muss einfach rechts
wegdrücken dann bekomme ich die zurück
dann ist die phase wieder weg dann
besteht hier noch eine anleitung zur
köln und auch deine freunde deine
platten benutzer gerade schon gezeigt
shift rechtecke die tele platte lass
deine freunde die platte mit dem tele
platten registriere rechts klicken
zusichert kannst du dir keine platten
wir machen erstmal dass sie mit lass
deine freunde die platte mit dem titel
platten registrieren rechts klicken
nötig wird es auf keinem server und ich
habe jetzt auch keinen server in die von
nitrat oder so dagegen anderen server
anbieter und ich hab auch keine freunde
allerdings könnten jetzt wenn ich auf
einem server bin könnte jetzt mein
kumpel mein portal hier sehen und ich
sagt hayden noch ein portal mit ich
schiffs nickel nach rechts weg das
portal ist ja jetzt ist offen und dann
könnte mein freund beispielsweise mit
seinem tele platten registriere dahin
gehen dass rechts klicken und dann den
zu seinen koordinaten hinzufügen also zu
den koordinaten die ihr gleich
eingeblendet wenn ich jetzt hier so
stehe da würde der dann per fax mit
seinem tele platten register rächt sich
machen am erstmal seinen koordinaten
könnte das meine ich sogar auch noch
selbst benennen und dann hätte er quasi
hier dann auch zu hause mit drinnen
seiner liste
wer ganz cool und was sonst noch in der
beschreibung steht zur sicherheit kannst
du keine platten entfernt welche von
anderen erstellt wurden wenn kein ab die
tele platte registriert hat kannst du
sie mit shift rechtsweg zurücksetzen
ja das ist eine ganz simple sache und
zwar einfach wenn die nicht registriert
ist kann man nicht zurücksetzen weil die
dann quasi heute doch keinen gehört
allerdings platten die von anderen
gemacht wurden kann man natürlich nicht
einfach kaputt machen also das kann ja
nicht sein dass sich jemand einen scheck
von macht und manchmal einmal die checks
wahlkampf kaputt quasi und er kann da
nicht mehr hin laufen
das war es auch schon mit der
modifikation was wir jetzt allerdings
mal testen können das habe ich mich
schon die ganze zeit gefragt wollte es
allerdings mit euch zusammen testen und
zwar ihr seht schon was im inventar habe
ich habe auf sieht ja nicht bei
net-a-porter natürlich meine lieben
freunde wir testen ob das ganze auch
immer möglich ist die punkt punkt wir
gehen mal eben kurz herein nehmen uns
dann gleich mal eben die tele platte
setzen eine in den nenner und versuchen
dann uns vom neckar wieder in die
normale welt zu teleportieren also
netter ist das ganze selbstverständlich
auch möglich sehen wir dadurch und ich
kann mich sogar nach hause teleportieren
perfekt das funktioniert sogar nachts
nicht nur blumen sondern auch welten
übergreifend nur noch mal kurz schauen
ob das ganze ist wenn ich jetzt hier net
ag natürlich anders rum klappt dann
selbstverständlich auch
und wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise auch
mal hier ein hinsetzt oder so nenne ich
jetzt bekam ich nenne ihn einfach mal
hell
ob ich mich dann auch nach vorne
teleportieren kann also das ist schon
sehr sehr cool aus bonn hier eigentlich
im netz gewesen
kann ich dann auch hier never ja kann
ich direkt die ladezeit ist natürlich
kürzer weil wir keine neue welt an
geladen werden muss aber ich denke meine
lieben freunde ich konnte euch das ganze
ganz gut bei bringen zeigen keine ahnung
in der druck ist irgendwie so ein
bisschen aber ich denke das liegt auch
an der version weil bei mir sind hier
noch 20 millionen mods drin geladen das
ist immer diese minecraft version wo ich
alle möglichen mods mit vorstelle
die 15 7.10 forge ist das für die
modifikation findet ein download-link in
der beschreibung wenn es euch gefallen
hat würde ich mich über eine bewertung
freundes ein klitzekleiner klick und
morgen wird wahrscheinlich in der
challange kommen mit max egger
krankhafter wenn wir nach köln fahren
wollten und so weiter und so fort und
dann wird auch demnächst mal das erste
mal dass minecraft wer bin ich kommen
und morgen keine ahnung was wollt ihr
endlich mal wieder so sehen wollte immer
wieder irgendwie so ein ipad spiel sehen
oder irgendwann computerspiel wo ich im
ausraster oder sollte vielleicht mal
wieder fifa sehen weil da habe ich zum
beispiel einen controller tisch der ich
ja schon verkauft hab jetzt hier nur
noch eine ps4 controller und zwar habe
ich bei meinem anderen psp controller
wenig aus gast habe ich gegen die
bildschirme geworfen da ist hierbei dem
bildschirm ein zweiter bildschirm ist
eine kleine schramme jetzt bin und
dieser controller den ich kaputt gemacht
hatte da konnte man also diese taste so
drehen
diese extrakte war eingedrückt und hier
hinten rechts ist die taste rausgeflogen
also ich hatte zwei weiß ich hab davon
sogar ein bild bei twitter gepostet
glaube ich damals wo die taste haus
geflogen ist also falls echten spiel da
ist die tonspur die ganze zeit nicht so
normal sondern die ganze halt so da bin
ich immer am rumschreien aber na ja
keine ahnung schreibt mir was ihr sehen
will wild volt und wir sehen uns dann
endlich in dem anderen video wieder
findet endlich bekommen freunde noch mal
zum abschluss hier kriegt er noch einen
kleinen zaun vorgespielt ich liebe
die
so affig wenn ich diese videos auf